calorimetry refers to the measurement
of heat flow and there are many
different types of calorimeters
in this case we're looking at a constant
volume
calorimeter which is also called a bomb
calorimeter
let's look at how a bomb calorimeter
works first the sample
to be combusted is placed in a container
that has some oxygen
and then there's some ignition wires
that go into this
this little container here and the
sample is ignited and heat is given off
by the combustion reaction
so heat is being transferred from our
sample
to the water in our container so let me
go ahead and draw some water in here so
imagine
we have some water and it's important to
note that the container is
rigid so the walls the walls are are
very are very solid and cannot move
there's also something to stir the water
and since heat is being transferred from
the combustion reaction
to the water the temperature of the
water will increase which we can see
on the thermometer now that we
understand
how a bomb calorimeter works let's think
about that heat that's being transferred
from the combustion reaction
to the water so that heat is
q let's go back to the first law of
thermodynamics which says that the
change in the internal energy of the
system
is equal to q plus w where q is the heat
that's transferred
and w is the work done let's say we do
this combustion reaction
in a container with a movable piston
and the combustion reaction is performed
under the constant pressure
of the atmosphere so this time when we
do the combustion reaction
we we will transfer some heat so heat is
being transferred from the combustion
reaction and we would also produce some
gases
which would push up on the pistons and
so the piston would move
up and since the piston is moving work
is being done
by the combustion reaction in this case
the heat that's transferred
q is done under constant pressure and so
we can write
qp here and by definition the heat
that's transferred at constant pressure
that's the change in the enthalpy delta
h
so for this example with the container
with the movable piston
when we did our combustion reaction the
heat that's transferred at constant
pressure is equal to the enthalpy delta
h
the change in enthalpy delta h and as
the gases expand and push in the piston
work
is done let's compare the example with
the movable piston to
our bomb calorimeter our bomb
calorimeter has rigid walls and
therefore
no work can be done so the work done
is equal to zero when we plug that into
the first law of thermodynamics
we find that the change in the internal
energy
delta e is equal to the heat
transferred q and since this is a
constant
volume calor calorimeter right the the
walls are rigid
we can write q sub v here
so this heat that's transferred from our
combustion
reaction in this case is not equal to
the change in the enthalpy
it's equal to the change in the internal
energy delta e
so the heat that's transferred at
constant pressure is equal to the change
in the enthalpy delta h
while the heat that's transferred at
constant volume is equal to the change
in the internal energy
delta e to do a constant volume
calorimetry problem we need to know the
heat capacity of the calorimeter which
is symbolized by
c with a subscript cal
to find the heat capacity of the
calorimeter we need to combust something
that we know the exact amount of heat
for for example if you combust one
exactly one gram of benzoic acid you'll
get 26.38
kilojoules released of energy
so let's say we have a 0.2350 gram
sample of benzoic acid
and we put that in our calorimeter and
we go ahead and combust the benzoic acid
and we find that the temperature
increases by positive 1.642 degrees
celsius to find the heat capacity for
the calorimeter first we take our known
amount which was 26.38
kilojoules per gram and we multiply that
by
how much benzoic acid we used in our
calorimeter which was 0.2350
grams and so the grams will cancel out
and this is equal to 6.199
kilojoules next we divide this by
our temperature change which was
positive 1.65
degrees celsius and this gives us the
heat capacity
of of our calorimeter which turns out to
be
3.3.775
kilojoules per degree celsius
now that we know the heat capacity for
our specific calorimeter
we can use this value to calculate the
heat of combustion for another substance
so the heat of combustion for another
substance or just q
would be equal to the negative of the
heat capacity of the calorimeter
times the change in the temperature of
the water in that calorimeter
let's say our goal is to calculate the
heat of combustion of caffeine
in kilojoules per mole so we take 0.265
grams of caffeine we put that
in our calorimeter we combust it and we
find the temperature of the water
increases by
positive 1.525 degrees celsius
so to calculate q q is equal to the
negative
of the heat capacity of the calorimeter
which is 3.775
kilojoules per degree celsius
and we multiply that by the temperature
change which is 1.525
degrees celsius so degrees celsius
cancels out
and this gives us negative 5.757
kilojoules and technically this is the
heat transfer to constant volume so we
can even write q sub v
in here and remember this is equal to
the change
in the internal energy of our system so
this is qv
is equal to delta e since our goal is to
find the heat of combustion of caffeine
and kilojoules per mole
next we need to take our grams of
caffeine which is 0.265 grams and divide
that by the molar mass of caffeine
and so grams will cancel out and give us
moles of
caffeine so this calculation is equal to
1.36 times
10 to the negative third
moles of caffeine now all we have to do
is divide our heat which is negative
5.757
kilojoules by our moles of 1.36
times 10 to the negative third moles
to give us a final value of negative
4.23
times 10 to the third kilojoules
per mole with the negative sign meaning
heat is given
off so we can say that this is the value
this is the change in the internal
energy for our reaction in kilojoules
per mole
and often the change in enthalpy is
about the same
as the change in the internal energy so
we can say that this is approximately
equal to
the change in the enthalpy for the
reaction as well